efftivement ces images comment avez-vous
à titre personnel vécu cette cette
réunion c'est la première fois que vous
vous retrouvez en face du chef de l'État
dans dans un tel contexte avec autant de
pouvoirs c'est on dé fait la première
fois c'était
impressionnant cette réunion se devait
quelque peu formelle elle a tout de même
était très chaleureuse il y a autour de
cette table des hommes de
courage tous le sont d'une certaine
façon je parlais là du courage politique
en situation et ça nous amène à parler
de ce qu'on appelle
l'ouverture tout de suite reprenons la
formule de Mercurol il y a ce qui il y a
ceux qui il y a ceux qui devrai être là
qui ne sont pas là les centristes par
exemple pourquoi à l'exception de
Durafour et de
Pelletier je crois que l'important c'est
que tout le monde en France comprenne
bien ce qui se passe qui n'est pas très
très simple mais qui est pourtant
limpide dès qu'on le décrit la gauche et
la droite ça existe partout dans le
monde ça existe dans les démocraties ça
existe en France DEP des décennies
autour de quoi de problème l'église
l'argent l'église il y a plus de matière
de décision de puissance publique on ne
se bat plus les esprits s'apèisent
l'argent toujours un vrai problème
toujours un vrai problème comment le
partager quel pouvoir ont ceux qui en
ont le vrai problème gauche droite et
puis nous monte un nouveau problème
énorme la France est à deux vitesses
nous avons des forts des performants des
exportateurs 129 entreprises en pointe
mondial tous leurs cadres sont bien
formés tous leurs ouvriers sont fiers et
bien payés et compétents puis nous avons
la France de petite vitesse d'abord
l'essentiel de la population féminine
vite marginalisé sur le marché du
travail un quart sinon 40 % nos
jeunes beaucoup des travailleurs
étrangers que nous avons fait venir nous
l'oublions jamais et c'est par rapport à
ceuxa que se pose le problème et il y a
au fond de politique une politique place
au fort n'emput-ons pas le train rapide
de charge pour aider les autres tant pis
et sil se fchent police et puis il y a
la politique de la France solidaire des
valeurs de la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme de ce que le président de la
République qui vient d'être réélu à ce
titre appelle les valeurs républicaines
manifestement cette bataille là
excusez-moi mais j'ai fini presque cette
bataille là ne coupe pas la France au
même endroit que l'autre et c'est la
difficulté manifestement vous souhaitiez
et vous souhaitez toujours j'imagine que
socialiste et centriste se retrouve
justement sur cette ligne la ligne de la
solidarité pas de
définition organique les socialistes
plus tous qui se reconnaissent dans les
valeurs républicaines quand le problème
de savoir si les exclus on les traite
par la répression par le rejet ou en
leur donnant une aide à s'insérer et
cetera est-ce que T ce soyons là-dessus
bien clair tous ceuxl qui ne sont pas
seulement des centristes qui ne sont pas
tous les centristes mais chez les
centristes il y en a beaucoup peuvent se
retrouver autour d'une majorité
républicaine c'est possible est-ce que
vous avez tendu la main au cours de ces
48 heures à ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour
François V mais mais la main é étendue
par une autorité plus forte que la
mienne le président de la République l'a
constamment dit l'a écrit dans ses
lettre à tous les Français l'a répété le
soir de de la victoire électorale et
puis mardi dès lundi et mardi sont tombé
des déclarations graves respectables
légitimes loyales et parfaitement
courtoise de monsieur le Président
liscardestin de Monsieur le Premier
Ministre raymonb de Madame Simone veille
de la formation centriste de la
formation UDF à
l'unanimité refusant toute hypothèse de
de gouvernement de concentration
républicaine oui mais ils disent qu'ils
attendaient oui c'est vrai mais ils
disent qu'ils attendaient de connaître
votre
projet c'est un faux semblant cela il a
rarement été mené une campagne
électorale présidentielle avec un
document aussi dense et aussi précis sur
les orientations par la table des
matières administratives des décrets
mais les orientations sont claires que
la lettre à tous les Français on ne peut
pas dire cela est-ce que vous allez
faire une déclaration de politique
générale à l'Assemblée est-ce que vous
allez demander la confiance à
l'assemblée qui est dominée je le
rappelle par le RPR et l'UDF
actuellement cette décision dépend du
autre et cet autre c'est le fait de
savoir si le président après avoir
terminé ses consultations il est en
train de le faire termine demain matin
va dissoudre ou non et là quel est le
problème si nous ne dissolvons pas si le
président de la République pardon don
qui a seule autorité pour en décider ne
dissous pas cela veut dire que nous
cherchons inlassablement à réaliser
cette ouverture dans les esprits dans
les cœurs dans les projets dans les
hommes mais cela veut dire que le
gouvernement de la République française
n'a pas de jorité que dans toute
négociation internationale grave il en
est en cours un sommet européen vient
nous serions sous suspicion de pouvoir
nous mettre faire mettre en minorité à
l'Assemblée nationale le lendemain ce
n'est ni conforme aux intérêts de la
France à sa réputation internationale et
surtout pas à l'esprit de la 5e
républiquecun voulait la sauver nous la
sauverons monsieur le prier ministre
dans le cas inverse si on dissou on se
retrouve dans la bataille droite gauche
classique avec coincé dans ce qu'on
appelle classiquement la droite quantité
de républicains solidaires du président
de la République et Don certains ont
voté pour lui d'ailleurs au nom des
valeurs républicaines du refus d'
l'explusion de la France solidaire et
nous retardons l'ouverture je veux dire
seulement que quelle que soit la
décision prise la volonté d'ouverture
reprendra dès le lendemain elle sera
manifestée par les textes législatifs
proposés elle sera faite dans l'offre de
composition du gouvernement dès le
lendemain s'il y a dis solution et quel
qu'en soit le résultat vous venez
Monsieur le Premier Ministre de
confirmer implicitement l'information
que j'ai tout à l'heure on parle d'une
dissolution elle serait annoncée demain
vous m'informez moi-même sur la date et
même sur la décision je veux dire ici à
quel point le président de la République
était soucieux de tout entendre de
pousser sa réflexion dans le plus
extrême détail de l'analysse des
conséquences de l'une ou l'autre
solution ce qui est d'ailleurs garant du
fait que si la dissolution est se situe
dans les contraintes tactiques les
contraintes tactiques ne seraiient
l'emportter sur la stratégie qui est la
recherche de l'ouverture disons
républicaine ou disons solidaire je me
souviens de la déclaration du chef de
l'État ici même le 22 mars il avait dit
je formerai le gouvernement c'est fait
vous êtes le premier ministre si je ne
dissouderai pas mais si ce gouvernement
est empêché de gouverner par l'Assemblée
nationale alors je dissoudrai pourquoi
ne pas attendre un discours de politique
générale de Monsieur Rocard du Premier
ministre et attendre un vote éventuel de
l'Assemblée mais monsieur Hamard parce
que
les personnes concernées c'est-à-dire
les responsables politiques de cette
droite républicaine on rendu le service
à la 5e République d'accélérer les
choses pour que nous soyons dans
l'instabilité aussi brièvement que
possible la réponse négative a été
officiellement et publiquement donnée
dans la journée de mardi pour
l'essentiel par Monsieur GIS gardestin
par Monsieur bar par Madame veille et
par l'unanimité de l'UDF le texte est
clair nous avons reçu une réponse
négative bien est-ce la composition du
gouvernement n résulté d'ailleurs est-ce
que ça n'est pas une occasion manquée
est-ce qu'une nouvelle campagne
électorale ne va pas nous faire retomber
dans ce schéma de droite gauche que vous
que vous regrettez vous-même alors c'est
c'est une occasion partie manquée par
ceux qui n'ont pas voulu la prendre
laissez-moi au passage souligner le
courage des responsables politiques ils
sont trois monsieur Durafour monsieur
beltier monsieur Stoleru qui ont accepté
d'anticiper et de rejoindre la majorité
de la solidarité la majorité
républicaine autour du président de la
République avant que la remise en ordre
du dispositif de combat électoral ne se
soit faite ces hommes sont courageux
certains ici ou là les Appell on des
traîtres moi je les appelle des
courageux il est dans la ligne
continuelle de leur conduite et de leurs
écrits d'avoir été euh des soutiens
actifs des valeurs républicaines il se
retrouent là où ils pouvait être doivent
être et il était d'autre part essentiel
que la totalité des composantes du Parti
socialiste soit solidaire de cette
volonté d'ouverture certains ent surpris
mais ce sont tous les socialistes qui
marchent ensemble on a même dit Valence
est revenue euh c'était irréfléchi et
très probablement stupide
les d'ailleurs Valence n'était pas ce
que l'on croit les discours de membres
du gouvernement à Valence cétait
justement des appels à la modération et
à l'esprit de responsabilité on l'a un
peu oublié mais les socialistes n
réfléchi sur eux-mêmes nous sommes des
hommes d'expérience et nous sommes
capables d'évoluer vous avez
personnellement téléphoner à Madame
veille à Monsieur bar pour tenter de les
convaincre je ne répondrai pas à des
questions indiscrètes qui mettent en
cause des personnes privées autres que
moi-même merci je rappelle que ce matin
vous aviez complété votre gouvernement
en annonçant la nomination de 15
secrétaires d'État dans leur majorité
les les postes clés reviennent au
socialistes et l'ouverture politique se
limite là aussi à la présence de de
trois personnalités de sensibilité
centriste nous vous retrouvons dans
quelques instants je voudrais ajouter
une phrase oui allez-y je vous en prie
je ne pense pas que dans l'histoire de
la 5e République il existe un seul
gouvernement créé après une victoire
présidentielle où la force politique app
à laquelle appartenait le président élu
et relativement aussi peu de ministres
et où il est un aussi grand nom ministre
ministre délégé secrétaire d'État de
personnes extérieures à son propre parti
vous comptez les soci professionnelles
effectivement naturellement il ce sont
des hommes libres il sont pas
socialistes nous allons faire le point
avec Véronique Saint-Olive et Henry elle